>>> ALL RIGHT, INCOMING
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN-ELECT
GEORGE SANTOS NOW ADMITTING THAT
HE LIED ABOUT HIS EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT HISTORY.
HE CONFESSED THAT HE NEVER
GRADUATED FROM A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY AFTER SAYING HE
GRADUATED FROM BERUCHE COLLEGE,
HE NEVER WORKED FOR CITIGROUP OR
GOLDMAN SACHS DESPITE SAYING HE
DID.
HE SAID HE'S SORRY FOR
EMBELLISHING HIS RECORD.
>> I'M NOT A FRAUD.
I'M NOT A CRIMINAL WHO DEFRAUDED
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND MADE UP
THIS FITITIOUS CHARACTER AND
RAN FOR CONGRESS.
I'VE BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME.
THEY KNOW ME.
THEY HAVE DONE BUSINESS DEALINGS
WITH ME.
I'M NOT GOING TO MAKE EXCUSES
FOR THIS, BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
OVERSTATED THEIR RESUMES OR
TWIST A LITTLE BIT OR -- I'M NOT
SAYING I'M NOT GUILTY OF THAT.
IF I DISAPPOINTED ANYONE BY
RESUME EMBELLISHMENT, I'M SORRY.
>> JOINING US NOW IS MICHAEL
GOLD WHO IS ONE OF THE TWO "NEW
YORK TIMES" REPORTERS WHO BROKE
THE STORY ON GEORGE SANTOS AND
THE DISCREPANCIES.
THE HEADLINE, WHO IS GEORGE
SANTOS?
HIS RESUME LARGELY FICTION, THAT
LED US TO NOW WHERE WE ARE WITH
THESE INTERVIEWS HE'S DOING.
IT IS MORE THAN JUST OVERSTATING
HIS RESUME, ISN'T IT?
>> I THINK THAT CASE CAN BE
MADE.
MR. SANTOS SAID HE GRADUATED
FROM BERUCHE IN 2010.
HE SAYS HE NEVER GRADUATED FROM
ANY INSTITUTION OF HIGHER
LEARNING NOW.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIS
EDUCATIONAL BACKGROUND.
THAT'S A HOLE THERE.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH THE NEW
YORK POST AND WABC HE SAID HE
MISSPOKE WHEN HE SAID HE WORKED
DIRECTLY FOR CITIGROUP AND
GOLDMAN SACHS.
HE'S VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT THE JOB
TITLES THERE, THE ORDER IN WHICH
HE HAD THOSE POSITIONS.
SO THAT'S A PLACE TO START I
THINK IN TERMS OF FIGURING OUT
WHERE THE TRUTH ACTUALLY LIES
HERE.
>> I MEAN, WHERE DO YOU EVEN
BEGIN?
BUT, ONE OF THE -- WHAT APPEARS
TO BE A LIE IS SOMETHING HE SAID
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE NATIONAL
TRAGEDY AND THAT IS THE PULSE
NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING BECAUSE HE
CLAIMED THAT FOUR OF THE PEOPLE
MURDERED THERE WORKED FOR HIM.
ANTHONY WEINER WHO WORKS FOR
WABC NOW ASKED HIM ABOUT THIS IN
THIS RADIO INTERVIEW.
I WANT PEOPLE TO LISTEN.
>> WERE YOUR GRANDPARENTS
REFUGEES THAT SURVIVED THE
HOLOCAUST?
>> I NEVER SAID THEY WERE
HUNGARIAN.
>> I'M SORRY.
UKRAINIAN.
FORGIVE ME.
>> UKRAINE -- SO MY FATHER
UKRAINIAN, MY GRANDMOTHER
BELGIUM, THAT'S THE STORY.
HE GOES FROM UKRAINE TO BELGIUM,
THEY GO TO BRAZIL.
>> SO, REPORTS YOUR GRANDPARENTS
WERE BORN IN BRAZIL ARE WRONG?
>> TO THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE,
NO.
>> GOT IT.
DID ANYONE THATISH IN THE PULSE
SHOOTING?
>> WE HAD PEOPLE WHO WERE BEING
HIRED BY THE COMPANY AT THE
TIME -- I WAS IN FLORIDA DURING
THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING, AT
A DIFFERENT NIGHTCLUB, BUT WE
DID LOSE FOUR PEOPLE WHO WERE
GOING TO BE COMING TO WORK FOR
THE COMPANY.
>> NOW, CONGRESSMAN --
>> WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> SO, PROBABLY IMPORTANT TO
START WITH WHERE THESE PULSE
COMMENTS FIRST CAME UP IN AN
INTERVIEW SHORTLY AFTER THE
CONGRESSMAN-ELECT WON OUT IN
LONG ISLAND, HE TOLD WNYC HIS
COMPANY AT THE TIME LOST FOUR
EMPLOYEES AT THE PULSE NIGHTCLUB
SHOOTING.
YOU HEAR IN THAT INTERVIEW, THE
LANGUAGE IS SHIFTING NOW.
THEY WERE IN THE PROCESS OF
BEING HIRED BY THE COMPANY.
THAT'S HARDER FOR US TO CONFIRM.
MY COLLEAGUE AND I REVIEWED
OBITUARIES AND NEWS CONFERENCE
OF ALL VICTIMS WHO DIED IN THAT
SHOOTING AND COULDN'T FIND ANY
FOUR THAT WORKED FOR THE SAME
COMPANY, LET ALONE THE ONES IN
MR. SANTOS' BIOGRAPHY.
THERE IS A LOT TO EXPLORE HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT COMPANY HE'S
SPEAKING OF.
WE KNOW HE DID SPEND SOME TIME
IN ORLANDO.
AND IN FLORIDA IN 2016.
HE WAS REGISTERED TO VOTE THERE
IN THAT ELECTION.
SO I THINK WE'RE STILL EXPLORING
EXACTLY THE NATURE OF THOSE
CLAIMS.
AND TO THE OTHER POINT, HE'S
ALSO CLAIMED THAT HIS
GRANDPARENTS FLED HOLOCAUST ERA
PERSECUTION IN EUROPE.
CNN AS YOU KNOW AND THE FORWARD,
A JEWISH PUBLICATION, REPORTED
SUGGESTING THAT MAY NOT BE THE
CASE, THE TIMES HAS NOT
INDEPENDENTLY VERIFIED OR
CONFIRMED THAT.
>> YOU HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS FINANCES, SOMETHING
THAT HE SPOKE ABOUT IN THE RADIO
INTERVIEW, SAYING, YES, HE'S HAD
THESE FINANCIAL DIFFICULTIES,
HE'S TALKED ABOUT REAL ISSUES
THAT IF THEY ARE TRUE OBVIOUSLY
ARE GENUINE THINGS THAT OTHER
PEOPLE STRUGGLED WITH.
WHEN IT COMES TO WHAT HIS
FINANCES LOOK LIKE, HE TALKS
ABOUT THIS, BUT HE DID LOAN
HIMSELF $700,000, HIS CAMPAIGN,
THIS ELECTION CYCLE.
WHAT QUESTIONS DO YOU STILL HAVE
ABOUT GEORGE SANTOS.
>> I THINK A BIG QUESTION FOR US
IS WHERE THAT MONEY CAME FROM,
AND WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING THERE
IS ANYTHING UNTOWARD ABOUT IT.
BUT IN A FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE,
HE FILED WITH THE HOUSE DURING
HIS RUN IN 2020, HE SUGGESTED HE
WAS MAKING $55,000 A YEAR.
HIS CAMPAIGN WAS LOANED
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS MONEY BY HIM
DURING THAT ELECTION THAN IN
2022 HE SAYS HE'S MAKING A
$700,000 SALARY, HIS COMPANY IS
DOING DIVIDENDS OF 1 TO $5
MILLION.
WE DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT WHAT
THIS COMPANY DOES, WE DON'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT ITS BUSINESS MODEL
OR WHO ITS CLIENTS ARE AND YOU
WANT TO KNOW TO WHO THEY'RE
WORKING WITH AND WHO THEY'RE
DOING BUSINESS WITH.
>> WANTING A CHANCE TO RESPOND
TO -- BECAUSE EVERY TIME YOU'VE
DONE AN ARTICLE INCLUDING FRONT
PAGE OF THE TIMES AGAIN TODAY,
YOU HAVE ASKED FOR HIM TO TALK
TO YOU, RIGHT?
>> YES.
>> AND HE'S DECLINED EVERY TIME?
>> WE HAVE YET TO SPEAK TO MR.
SANTOS.
WE HAVE SPOKEN TO HIS
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> HE WENT AFTER YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" IN THIS INTERVIEW SAYING
YOU, QUOTE, MADE IT -- YOU MADE
IT YOUR MISSION TO SLANDER ME.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> GRACE AND I STAND BY THE
REPORTING WE HAVE DONE AND THE
FOLLOW-UP STORIES.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE STORIES
WE HAVE WRITTEN, NOT THE MANY
FOLLOW-UPS THAT HAVE BEEN DONE.
ONE THING THAT MR. SANTOS SAID
IN HIS INTERVIEWS YESTERDAY IS
THAT HE DENIES EVER COMMITTING
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THERE IS A REPORT THAT WE FOUND,
A COURT CASE IN BRAZIL, THAT WE
PULLED UP, THAT SUGGESTS THAT HE
HAS ADMITTED TO A CASE OF CHECK
FRAUD AND ONE THING WE HAVE SEEN
IS THAT BRAZILIAN MEDIA OUTLETS
RELEASED NEW DETAILS AND DELVED
INTO THAT MORE AND CORROBORATED
OUR REPORTING.
>> HE ALSO CORROBORATED YOUR
REPORTING BY ADMITTING THAT HE
LIED ABOUT THOSE BIG PARTS OF
HIS RESUME THAT YOU FIRS